wales has just begun a new nationwide  lockdown  the welsh government says the fire break  restrictions in place  for 17 days will help protect the  country's nhs  from being overwhelmed well the circuit  breaker got underway just a few moments  ago  and it means all but essential retail  outlets are closed including pubs  restaurants and hairdressers households  are now banned from mixing both indoors  and outdoors primary schools will open  after the half-term  week though secondary schools will open  only two pupils  in year seven and eight libraries and  community centres  have closed places of worship remain  open but for funerals and wedding  ceremonies  only